c'est une guerre qui fait des ravages
horribles et qui a des répercussions
partout dans le monde la Chine est une
puissance mondiale qui bouleverse de
plus en plus lors d'international on
veut une augmentation de 35 % de nos
dépenses en santé mais sans conditions
d'immigrations et d'intégration qui
tient compte de notre contexte
nord-américain
[Musique]
il y a des événements qui viennent
changer l'actualité sans qu'on ne les
voit venir il y en a aussi dans le
profil se dessine peut-être plus
rapidement on va se concentrer
maintenant sur cette dernière catégorie
demandons-nous quels enjeux devrait-on
surveiller dans les prochains mois et
pourquoi on va faire au Canada
commençons par les provinces Michel je
commence avec vous qu'est-ce qu'on
devrait surveiller province Québec ou
une province au cours des prochains mois
au Québec je pense dans d'autres
provinces aussi également
la fatigue énorme des employés du
système de santé un système qui est sur
le bord de l'implosion qui se remet pas
de la pandémie qui a encore autant de
problèmes et là ça marchera plus avec
des lettres ouvertes du ministre de la
Santé pour dire on a essayé de faire des
reformes tout le monde comprend là que
il faut quelque chose de beaucoup plus
grand entre autres une injection fort
mais plus que ça aussi et tout ce
système là et sur vraiment sur le bord
de l'inclosion
ça ça va pas bien dans les hôpitaux un
peu partout au travers de pays j'entends
qu'est-ce qu'on surveille vous au Québec
ou une province moi j'ai regardé plutôt
les matchs électoraux etc de la
prochaine année dans une autre vie je
vous aurais dit on serait juste un
Trudeau pour voir si votre démissionner
je crois que c'est une année carte qui
va qui sérieusement veut rester où je
vous aurais dit une élection fédérale
mais j'ai l'impression que le pacte avec
le NPD va tenir pour l'année donc j'ai
choisi les élections en Alberta en mai
parce que ça va permettre de porter un
jugement sur les grands projets de
Madame Smith qu'allaient que décrit de
façon assez exact
d'une part d'autre part grosse nouvelle
pour les NPD revenait au pouvoir en
Alberta c'est pas possible parce que
cette province là va aller aux urnes
quand même c'est pas trop mal de moins
en moins de vidéos dans les provinces en
passant ce serait probablement une
excellente nouvelle pour Pierre Poivre
si Madame noteley reprenait le pouvoir
avec le NPD en Alberta attend pour les
élections fédérales
une drôle d'amis ouais effectivement
avec un politique d'adversaire c'est
toujours plus efficace c'est plus
efficace effectivement moi j'ai choisi
la nouvelle politique d'immigration du
gouvernement du Québec les consultations
commencent en 2023 plan triennal avec ce
que François Legault a annonçait dans
son discours d'ouverture c'est à dire
qu'on veut une immigration davantage
francophone on va derrière le 100% ce
sera difficile mais on le souhaite avec
un accent mis sur les étudiants
étrangers qui s'intègrent plus
facilement ici reconnaissance des
diplômes cercle d'amis cercle de famille
à l'extérieur de Montréal notamment qui
est sur papier une bonne stratégie mais
on a besoin de ta voix pour l'accomplir
les visas des étudiants étrangers ça
passe par Ottawa entre autres alors il
faut mettre de l'huile dans la machine
plutôt que de tenter de l'enrayer ce que
le gouvernement de Go a souvent fait
dans le passé on aimerait bien ce que le
tailler sur Ottawa sur l'immigration
est-ce que Christine Frechette qui est
toute nouvelle va bien se débrouiller
dans cette nouvelle dynamique c'est à
dire d'avoir d'aller chercher des alliés
à Ottawa pour livrer des résultats là
être capable d'avoir quelque chose à
offrir comme politique d'immigration qui
encourage l'immigration francophone
comment elle va y arriver ça va être à
surveillant 2020 on aurait visé un peu
on a ajusté la cible on est moins
qu'ajuster on a fait volte-face complète
on est passé de je veux des pouvoirs
d'Ottawa je vais m'occuper de mes
pouvoirs mais de le faire correctement
changement complet de stratégie du côté
de François Legault ça peut être payant
encore faut-il être capable d'y arriver
puis c'est pour ça que ça va être en
2023 qu'on va voir comment ça va
fonctionner il y a pas dit référendum
sectoriel
on est passé de référendum sectoriel à
travailler au paiement ensemble mais
dans la main pour avoir plus de
francophones
en quelques semaines quelques mois
sur la scène sur la scène fédérale
Michel qu'est-ce que vous soyez
qu'est-ce qui devrait retenir notre
attention dans les premiers mois de 2023
la situation économique est toujours
celle qui détermine les élections qui
déterminent plein de choses et la
situation de l'inflation on ne sait pas
encore de quel côté ça va aller beaucoup
de gens qui disent la dernière rose des
taux d'intérêt par la Banque du Canada
c'était la dernière on ne le sait pas
c'est une situation qui touche vraiment
beaucoup directement les gens le prix du
panier d'épicerie etc et bien sûr c'est
un effet sur la politique et sur les
prochaines élections donc si un mauvais
tournant dans l'inflation ça pourrait
être très dangereux
ça a été ça a été l'élément avec lequel
Pierre pollièvre a mener à peu près
toutes les périodes de questions depuis
son arrivée voilà et les tarifications
sur le carbone à Ottawa que vous n'avez
pas fait bouger l'aiguille des sondages
en passant le dossier du financement de
la santé parce que je pense que pas
seulement au Québec mais il y en a marre
un peu partout au Canada de regarder la
partie de ping-pong entre les premiers
ministres des provinces c'est pas lui
c'est moi c'est de sa faute il va
falloir un moment donné que Justin
Trudeau décide de s'asseoir avec ses
partenaires des provinces même si c'est
pour ne pas s'entendre mais cette espèce
de partie de ping-pong je pense que la
patience du public à l'égard de ça a pas
mal atteint ses limites je sais pas
convaincu que Monsieur Trudeau a les
moyens de ne pas s'asseoir ne serait-ce
que en terme de perception de l'opinion
dans l'opinion publique au cours des 6 7
8 9 derniers mois la malgré ce qu'on
vient de dire sur l'inflation qui est
totalement exacte la santé a dépassé
l'inflation dans les préoccupations des
Canadiens
quand on a un gouvernement minoritaire
qui un jour va devoir retourner aux
urnes et c'est le genre de données qui
s'appelle
occupe-toi en
je vais surveiller Christophe Freeland
parce que étant donné que j'entends
Hébert redit avec tout à fait
contre pierre-olienne que va faire la
vis Premier ministre et ministre des
Finances qu'on présume être en attente
pour le trône va-t-elle sagement
attendre que Justin Trudeau dans deux
trois ans affronte pierre polliève et on
verra dans quel état sera le Parti
libéral du Canada à ce moment-là où
va-t-elle être attiré par le chant des
sirènes
par exemple on dit qu'elle pourrait être
intéressé au poste de secrétaire général
de l'OTAN faut de retrouver un nouveau
secrétaire général l'automne prochain
donc avant les prochaines élections
fédérales
bon ça c'est très très rare ça arrive
jamais que le Canada est en liste pour
ce poste-là de l'automne là il y a une
conjoncture madame freelen parle
plusieurs langues sa mère est une Canada
joue un très gros rôle dans le conflit
en Ukraine est-ce qu'elle pourrait être
tentée de s'essayer et donc d'aller
faire la première bielle marche dans la
neige quelque part au printemps neige
tardive elle va pas décider sans janvier
dans les prochains mois c'est ce qui
complète cette tournée là vous pensez
peut-être déjà vu à la maison à ce que
vous allez offrir dans quelques semaines
aux résolutions que vous allez prendre
pour janvier que vous allez peut-être
respecter ou pas qu'en est-il de nos
politiciens aux collaborateurs ont
quelques idées en tête de résolution de
cadeaux on voulait partage au retour
[Musique]